- I didn't sign up for demons, okay?
I signed up for ghosts.
(wind and creaking)
- [Voiceover] My aunt sees dead people,
so my aunt's not lying to
everyone in the family.
She can't be lying to everyone.
She has some cool stories, though.
- I tried to contact my dead cat.
The next day, I woke up, put on pants
and there was cat hair on my pants.
- Middle of the day,
I see this white flash
of light go in front of me.
- [Male] Is there anyone here?
- [Female 1] It's doing something.
Anybody else freaked out?
- [Voiceover] Is there a good spirit?
Y, yes.
- [Male] Y.
- That's yes.
- [Female 1] Y. Yes. Okay.
- [Female 2] Can you tell us your name?
- (in unison) No.
- [Female 1] Maybe it's an animal.
- [Male] Oh my God.
- [Female 1] Are you...
- [Male] Are you an animal?
Yes, I did talk to my cat once.
- [Female 2] Y, yes.
- [Male] It's an animal.
- [Male] We have to ask the animals
questions they're used to hearing like
- [Male] Are you a
- [Female 1] Do they want
- [Male] good boy?
- [Female 1] a treat?
- [Female 1] Oh, boy.
- [Male] Oh, no. It's mad, it's mad.
It wants bye.
- [Female 2] A haunted goodbye.
- I'm starting to get a little concerned
about what I got myself into.
- [Female 2] At first,
I thought it was you,
but then I noticed that
your fingers were also
twitching and barely
- [Male] Shaking?
touching it and so I was like
- [Male] Yeah, that's out
"Ah, it's gotta be Jamie.
- [Male] of straight fear.
- I really just wanted
to take my fingers off.
- It was surreal.
Is there anyone here?
- [Female 1] Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, I'm not even touching this,
how is this even possible?
Seems like weird stuff is going on.
- [Female 2] Whoever's
here, are you a good spirit?
What's your name?
- [Male] It's going to Z, is that bad?
- [Female 1] Is that a U?
- Female 2] U.
- (in unison) S.
- [Female 2] Zus.
- [Male] Zus, I told you it was Zus.
- [Female 2] Zus, can you tell us
what year you died?
- [Female 1] Six, six
- [Female 2] Six.
- [Female 1] nine-six.
- [Male] nine-six.
- [Male] Did you die in 1996?
1896?
1796?
- [Female 1] Okay, we're
going to something.
Y, must be yes.
- [Male] That's yes.
- [Female 2] Y.
- [Male] We still don't know if
it's a good or a bad spirit?
- [Female 2] Yeah, it never answered.
- We'll regret this.
- [Female 1] I don't think we should
ask whether it's a bad spirit or not.
- [Male] I would like to
know if it is a bad spirit.
- [Female 1] I don't wanna
know, I don't wanna know.
- [Male] Carol?
- [Female 2] Zus,
are you a good spirit?
- [Female 1] I don't wanna know.
- [Male] No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
- [Female 1] No, no. Where are we going?
- [Male] No, no, no. Night is bad.
If everyone promises that
they weren't pushing it.
- [Female 2] I like pinky promise,
triple pinky promise.
- [Male] Cool, then goodbye.
(laughter)
Absolutely not.
- [Female 2] That did not just happen.
- [Male] The more I told myself
it's not real, don't believe it,
that didn't really happen,
it's like the more freaked out I got.
- [Female 1] I don't even know how
to explain what just happened
which must mean something
about it is real.
- [Female 2] I'm still scared.
(ghostly noises)